first up eggs bait in hash browns
the secret of a great hash brown are the
potatoes
i prefer using really nice waxy potatoes
they cook better but more importantly
hold themselves together
we're not gonna slice the onion all the
potatoes but we're actually gonna grate
them
the potatoes get really nice and crispy
i mean seriously crispy
now the onion
that way you get that nice balance of
that onion flavor running through
every little shard of potato
[Music]
season with salt pepper olive oil and km
give that a really good mix through
and then squeeze all that water out
and look at all that juice we squeeze
out there really important
the more liquid you remove the crispier
your hash browns will be
nice large pan put that on once the
pan's hot
pour in a good glug of olive oil
[Music]
that sound confirms how important it is
to have your pan
nice and hot so it seals
the grated potato onion together so take
the spoon
and just pat it down what we're trying
to do now is get it really nice and
compact
going around the outside of the pan with
little flecks of butter
you just slip them down the back gently
and that gets the onions caramelised
here's a great tip for turning your hash
browns over
quick and easy take a plate
place it on top and just
flip it over and then slide it back in
very quickly you see the color we've got
on there now
got that nice crispy texture
of the potato i'm going to use the hash
brown as a bed for my baked eggs
crack in your eggs nice and gently just
a little sprinkling of the cayenne
to make the eggs a little bit spicy then
into a preheated oven
for six to eight minutes meanwhile onto
my bacon
and i'm giving it a classic american
twist now one thing i could never get my
head around when i first
started eating lots of american
breakfast was the sweetness from the
bacon
i've grown up to love that combination
of smoky sweet flavors
and it's so easy pan on and simply heat
olive oil
brown sugar salt and pepper and butter
bacon in and as it cooks it becomes
irresistibly caramelized and golden
brown
tofu gas and my glazed bacon
absolutely ready beautiful now my hash
browns and baked eggs
are ready wow look at that
beautiful just put your spatula
underneath there
onto your plate and that bacon sets
beauty on top of the baked eggs and that
hash brown underneath and
you can see why the best breakfasts in
the world
are always in america
[Music]
this is an all-american superhero offer
breakfast
eggs baking hash browns with glazed
bacon
when it comes to cooking techniques
barbecue is virtually a religion in
america
especially in the southern states down
there the real barbecue pros use big
open fire pits
to get huge joints of meat super
succulent and fantastically perfumed
with smoke and spice so my ultimate
american dinner
has to include an amazing mouth in the
mouth barbecue beef
but i'm doing it the easy way cooked in
the oven low
and slow we're creating barbecue style
beef brisket
with crunchy coleslaw and sweet potato
wedges which will be right up her street
holly now
you love barbecues right so you're gonna
help me barbecue this delicious
piece of brisket brisket look at it
beautiful it's a very tough cut of meat
so it needs to be cooked slowly
so it gets really nice and tender are we
barbecuing it outside
we're gonna actually put the barbecue
flavor on there but we're gonna cook it
in the oven
okay so mustard powder okay
here we have some celery seed next
a little bit of salt in there okay
what's this here
cumin two again
nice good now this one
cayenne pepper absolutely right right
two teaspoons of that in there as well
good now what i want you to do
fresh pepper on there i'll give that a
little mix
roll up your little sleeves and then i
want you
to rub all that spice
into the brisket almost like you're
massaging it in there
good girl come on holes get your hands
nice and flat on there
good girl now that's nice and coated
okay in the spice so
gas on roasting tray on what we've got
to do now
with all those spices is sear them in a
couple of tablespoons of olive oil
into the tray
well done okay good that's getting nice
and hot now and you get your brisket
and all that spice lay that in there
nicely
okay so now we'll start coloring it
as you start to sear in you smell those
spices
yep all that spice left on the plate
we're gonna use yeah i want you to get
the onions
nice and carefully slice them down not
too thin
but just like you're chopping them take
your time
smell those spices now
good girl thank you wash my hands i can
rub my eyes
damn holly was homework that bad
no the onions oh no don't rub your eyes
don't rub your eyes we've got the colour
on the brisket okay yeah take that out
literally for 30 seconds okay onions
into the tray please
nice you see it's starting to smell
slightly barbecuey already
give that a little stir
nice now one nice tablespoon
of brown sugar what does the brown sugar
do dad so the brown sugar
you're gonna start caramelizing the
onions right from there
my bay leaves in please good girl oh
yes please right you want to take over
good careful that tray is very very hot
a tablespoon
of tomato puree roast that off at the
bottom of the tray
to really rub it in amongst the onions
good girl
now look at the color of the onions
right now
time for a little drink
for the brisket
okay one bottle of earring please so you
go in you put yours in there
i'll put mine here good good health to
you and your brisket
good health
bring that to the ball okay now this is
where it gets really exciting
i want you to lift the brisket up and
put it on top of the onions in she goes
good girl and then i want to pour the
stock all the way around please
i'm using beef stock but it will work
with chicken stock or even vegetable
stock
once the stock has come to the boil
cover tightly with foil
and just pinch in the ends
fat that down and then you just twist
all the way
so that's nice and tight that's the hard
work done thank you
simply pop it in the oven for three and
a half hours and as it cooks you can get
on with the side dishes
first job sweet potato wedges with some
serious flavor
start by making a spice mix in a dry pan
toast coriander seeds
until beautifully aromatic then put them
in a pestle and mortar
add salt and grind
[Music]
next smoked paprika dried oregano
cayenne pepper and mix spice mix done
now simply cut your sweet potatoes into
wedges toss in olive oil and thoroughly
cover
with the spice mix onto a baking tray
and into a preheated oven for 30 minutes
turning halfway
irresistible sweet potato wedgies are
ready now to finish off my beef
see that smell just sort of travels
everywhere
oh ah now look at that
so we can leave that to rest what does
resting mean resting means where you've
cooked a joint
and you just leave it to relax so it'll
make the meat so much more tender
okay right coleslaw traditionally you
would mix
slaw with what mayonnaise that's right
very nice
this time we're gonna do it a little
different so i'd like to put the yogurt
into the bowl for me
please all of it i'll start slicing the
white cabbage
and the red cabbage now from there a
nice tablespoon
of mustard in there please give that a
nice mix up
nice little touch of salt and pepper
okay now a little cider vinegar
so a little splash of cider vinegar in
there
okay as i shred this okay i'd like you
please then to get the red cabbage
and just open up into that and mix it in
at the same time
and then you fold that in there as i
start shredding
see how it's coming together yeah
right that's all the red cabbage now the
white
so you've got that nice vinegary
tartness to the slaw and the yogurt
keeps it nice and fresh
last little bit in one more little thing
so put some nice
chopped fresh chives in there and that
will give it this nice
light onion flavor
so chives in
[Music]
how's that now taste it with the chives
in there
delicious so i'd like you
to fill up the bowl i'm gonna very
carefully lift out
my brisket how come is it shrunk it's
been in the oven
for nearly three and a half hours so
it's been cooked slowly
that sits on there oh my goodness me let
me just show you what this looks like
i'll start slicing it and see how soft
look at that and here's the thing about
helping daddy cook
here's the perk you get to taste it
first
before anybody that is so good that
tastes delicious see all that wonderful
flavor
in there last job is to create an
incredibly quick and delicious sauce
gas on and reduce the spicy juices and
onions the beef cooked in
then add in cider vinegar and you've got
a brilliant tangy barbecue sauce
that smells nice doesn't it
wow that is brisket
and a half now the rest of it can go in
the gravy pot
that's a really nice rich
spicy barbecue
onion gravy
that my daddy is the perfect way
to serve brisket right you ready if you
carry
the sweet potato for me i've got the
brisket wow
let's go donny well done by the way
thank you
this is a real american beauty gorgeous
low and slow cooked barbecue beef
brisket with three potato wedges and
yogurt coleslaw
you